[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une forme une petite armée de bénévoles
tous vêtus de rose mobilisation
populaire pour les nids robredo actuel
vice présidente des philippines
visages de l'espoir pour grand nombre de
jeunes désillusionné par la gestion de
la pandémie dans un pays où lourd passé
politique
moins de corruption et plus de
programmes sociaux c'est ce que je
souhaite ce bénévole
maison philippines ou le quart de la
population vit dans la pauvreté un nom
familier ferdinand marcos fils rassure
il peut aider les moins fortunés croit
cette femme il pourrait faire baisser le
prix des denrées en étant élu et
c'est un secret de polichinelle explique
ce politologue le clan marcos prépare ce
moment depuis des années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui qu'on surnomme bang bang ferdinand
marcos fils s'est tourné vers les
réseaux sociaux dans un pays qui compte
l'un des plus grand nombre
d'utilisateurs au monde des informations
et occultation du passé le clan marcos a
réussi à faire oublier la violence et la
corruption qui ont régné sous le
dictateur marcos bang bang décrit même
son père comme un génie politique
des stocks
le clan marcos réécrit l'histoire est
présente les 20 ans de la dictature
comme une période de prospérité ce qui
attire de nombreux électeurs
amnesty international a recensé plus de
soixante dix mille cas de violation des
droits de la personne à l'époque
j'ai le sens qu'il vous dans les veines
dit cet ancien prisonnier politique les
traumatismes de l'air marcos remonte à
la surface avec cette campagne
électorale
[Musique]
c'est touchant
les partisans de lenny robredo eux
espèrent encore qu'ils pourront causer
malgré tout la surprise ici philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto